Benjamin Netanyahu is returning as
Israeli Prime Minister his new far-right
Coalition is being sworn in by
Parliament today the incoming government
is regarded as the most right-wing in
Israel's history and includes several
Ultra Orthodox and ultra-nationalist
parties the Coalition has vowed to
expand settlements in the occupied West
Bank and other disputed areas it's the
sixth government formed by Netanyahu who
is still on trial for alleged corruption
foreign
ERS is standing by inside the Israeli
Parliament the knesset and joins us now
Rebecca what can we expect from this new
government
well Michael we've just seen Benjamin
Netanyahu addressed the knesset opening
uh today's session and he spoke of
things that you know have already been
policy objectives of his in the past
including number one on the list was
stopping Iran become a nuclear power we
saw a talk of continuing peace
agreements with regional parties uh
these are either Abraham Accords which
we saw under his last tenure uh he also
spoke of of course some domestic issues
dealing with the cost of living and
those kind of things but they're not
really the issues that are ruffling
feathers here as you mentioned quite
rightly this is being seen as the most
right wing we're even hearing the word
extreme government that this country has
ever seen and it's some of the Coalition
agreements that have been signed with
this Coalition apart parties or partners
that are really roughening ruffling
feathers some of these agreements
include giving more direct control over
development of the West Bank to one of
the leaders of the extreme parties also
giving walk direct control over policing
the Border Police and some policing in
the West Bank as well over to another
member of these extreme coalitions now
these are two very significant
developments that have been ruffling
feathers both home and abroad
domestically inside Israel we're seeing
changes promised to the Supreme Court to
dismantle or take away power from the
Supreme Court we're also seeing promises
uh potentially of a discrimination law
that would make it legal for people to
discriminate on religious grounds so we
are seeing huge concerns both here and
abroad outside the knesset at the moment
we're seeing a big protest growing uh
people here you know Benjamin Netanyahu
does have a lot of support and his
Coalition Partners as well but around
about half of the country didn't vote
for them and that we're seeing those
concerns coming out it's a very big Day
in Israel today Michael Rebecca as you
well know the new cabinet includes a
number of avowed anti-arrat politicians
what might this mean for relations with
the Palestinian population
well not not good things they fear
Michael I mentioned a couple of the
policies there you've got two of these
leaders better smotrich and itamabenvian
are they are the two leaders that will
be now directly controlling the policing
of the West Bank and also the
development of settlements critics are
calling this a de facto annexation of
the West Bank these both men are
settlers themselves they're looking to
push forward they see this country as
one Israel and they're anti-2 States so
you know not good things to the
Palestinians Palestinians are
undoubtedly concerned but they also have
been saying that things have not been
good already before this government came
into Power we're you know we've seen one
of the deadliest years here in decades
there's more than 150 Palestinians and
at least 30 Israelis were killed this
year since January alone so things not
looking set to get anybody when it comes
to relations between Israelis and
Palestinians
that is uh Rebecca Ritter's for us there
in Jerusalem as ever Rebecca many many
thanks